Alright folks, welcome back.
This lesson is going to be on Forex and how we can apply this model to the FX market.
Now if you are a long time student of mine, a lot of the things I'm going to talk about
in here are going to be very familiar to you.
I promise you the things that the newer students that just found this channel are going to
feel like they're stuck on, majority of it is in the free lessons in this YouTube channel.
So I'm going to count you to go through those videos and you'll get your answers there.
Alright, so if we're looking at the Euro dollar, and I'll let you know that's what this is.
This is the daily chart for Euro.
I want you to take a look at how price moved above these relative equal highs, right here.
Now once it did that, this took the buy side or buy stops out of the marketplace here.
Then it started going lower.
What would it likely be reaching for?
Next, well it took buy side out here.
What do you think is resting below here?
Sell stops or sell side liquidity.
Now just to the left, notice these two little devils here, relative equal lows, and with
this one and this one, we have two areas of sell side liquidity.
Notice this candle here, which happens to be Monday's trading or yesterday's trading.
This low did not take out that low yet, notice that?
So we have unfinished business below here and potentially below here.
So if this is a daily chart, even though we've come from this high and had three consecutive
down close candles, what is the bias?
The very next candle, what's the bias going to be?
Bearish, we're anticipating bearishness going in.
So let's take that and flesh that out a little bit more.
So here is your chart that would be annotated and you'd have this level on your chart.
While you're learning, it's important to have these types of things on your chart.
Over time, all you need is a pad and something to write with and you'll write down the levels.
Majority of the time, the only time I'm showing a level on my chart is for teaching purposes.
I like to keep my chart clean and that way I'm not forcing that bias.
If I see something that would allow me to negate the whole premise that I went into
the market with and either reverse or move to the sidelines, I want that clarity.
Now I say that and some of you purists in here, they just simply want to do everything
I say and hang on every single one of my words.
Don't avoid or don't try to do it without having annotations like having levels drawn
on your chart because you need to train yourself to see it.
And what I mean by that, while having these relative equal highs highlighted, your buy
stops would be resting above here and the market will go just above that a little bit
and then once those buy stops are taken for anyone that's short, they're getting knocked
down in a loss and that flood of orders to be buying at the market is counter-party
to individuals that want to sell short.
So smart money is selling short up here with the expectation that it's going to go below
this low here, below here and potentially below that low down there.
So today's trading we had the open, it rallies up a little bit, then careens through the
short-term low here and below the relative equal lows here.
Not by much, we'll see it, but it's still there.
Now what level on the downside after this day closed, if we're looking for lower prices,
what could we expect it to draw to?
Obviously below here and below here, but what price level?
109, big figure.
So the big figure numbers or the zero levels, they're very influential because there's
lots of liquidity that is used around those levels, a lot of commerce, a lot of business
transactions that come in just for the sake of simplicity, zero zero level, the 20 levels,
the 50 levels and the 80 levels.
So I dubbed them institutional price levels, I teach that in the free videos in this YouTube
channel too.
All right, so we're going to drop down to an hourly chart, but before we get into that
I'm going to revisit the swing trading idea that I taught.
Highest up close or opening in this retracement up and the lowest open or close is here.
So I left the highlighted candles, so you can match that up on yours.
And then we have this old low, so below this old low, if it goes below that how many pips
can it go below that?
Well, we have the big figure 109, right?
Remember the previous chart here?
Watch.
Over here, that's essentially the 1.09 big figure.
So do we have any levels in here on the fib that correspond to that?
Well, we have 1.0919, that's possible.
Then we have 1.09101, that's another level that's possible.
And we have 1.09011, essentially almost the big figure, right?
So we have a standard deviation from this swing to here.
If this is broken, these are only true if this low is broken, okay?
So this is a fall crumb point and this is a fall crumb point.
So how do we know which level we're going to aim for?
Well, we have those relative equal lows at the 109 big figure level.
And then we have our fib calling for these levels down here and the lowest one without
going through 1.09 is this one here.
All right, on the hourly chart with our buy-side liquidity pool level here, the market trades
up into that area, absorbing all of that liquidity, then breaking down, takes out a short turn
low here and here and here, retraces up in, breaks lower, then we go into today's trading,
the fib.
Prior to the day starting, we know that it's likely to draw below here and then down to
that 109 big figure.
We have a lot of convergence around that 109 big figure.
At the beginning of the day at midnight, New York local time, that's going to be right
in here, if we see the market rally up, which is what we want to see, we want to see a protraction
in the marketplace where it starts to go against the expected direction of the move intraday.
So if we're bearish and we're looking for that 109 level to be traded to and attack
the liquidity below here, preferably we want to see it rally first.
That's the Judas swing.
That market protraction is what we're looking for for manipulation part of my concept Power
3, which is accumulation, manipulation, distribution.
So once the day begins at midnight, we're anticipating a move up.
What's it going to be trading up into?
This imbalance in here.
So once it does that, it kind of like forms the daily high and then the rest of the day
you're going to be looking for distribution throughout the day, looking for lower prices.
So inside that little shaded area, we're going to use that going forward.
So let's drop down to a lower time frame, 15 minute time frame.
Here is that imbalance that doesn't look that clean on a 15 minute time frame, but the hourly
is what we're framing it on.
Okay.
So the market trades up into that.
Here is the midnight New York local time candle on the 15 minute time frame chart.
Opening price is here, extended out throughout the day.
That is your midnight New York candle opening price.
If we're selling short, we want to see price trade above this opening price.
This is where smart money is accumulating short positions.
See that?
So the algorithm goes higher, once more higher, once more higher, and then again right here
and then begins its descent into the daily range low.
Now what's occurring here, this is not buying and selling pressure.
The algorithm is offering constantly price above this opening price.
Now every single time it rallies up, just because it does that doesn't necessarily mean
that's the time for you to get in.
But when you couple that with time of day and price, it becomes a lot better.
Notice we have an imbalance in here.
We have a fair value gap there and price runs up during the New York open kill zone.
Okay.
So I dubbed this specific time of day between seven o'clock in the morning New York time
to ten o'clock in the morning.
This is specific to Forex.
Okay.
These times are specific to FX pairs.
If you're going to trade an index, don't worry about that.
You can work with the 830 to 11 o'clock New York local time.
But for Forex, the algorithm is going to operate on these specific elements of time.
So if we're looking at this imbalance here, the market runs up and it overshoots the imbalance
a little bit.
But what's it really go to?
The last up close candle, which is a bearish order block.
How do we know it's a bearish order block?
Because we have the imbalance here and it's trading back up into after a nice move lower.
So this displacement, fair value gap, last up close candle, touches it, there's your
bearish order block.
Dropping down into a five minute chart, everything being as it was on the 15.
That's that order block here, just being shown on a five minute chart, but I'm adding now
the annotation of the New York open kill zone.
Seven o'clock in the morning begins here at the end of that line segment and ten o'clock
is here.
So everything underneath this end of the trend line here and below this part of it, this
all is during the New York open kill zone.
So you're hunting your setup for forex pairs within that little block of time.
So during this time, you're hunting your setup.
What price are you looking for?
Preferably at or just above the opening price at midnight.
Now if you are a New York session trader, you want to refer to the opening price at
midnight, but then you want to recalibrate at 830 and we'll look at that in a moment.
So for now, just notice looking at this particular day on the economic calendar, we had a high
impact news driver at ten o'clock in the morning.
It was the ISM services PMI number.
Now before you want to start sending me emails or start sending me essay questions in the
comment section of this video about what does the ISM PMI number do, what's it?
I don't care what these numbers are really discussing.
I don't care.
I don't care about the raw data.
I don't care what the expectation is.
I don't care.
What I'm expecting is the volatility in the marketplace at or around these specific times
because the algorithm is going to use that injection of volatility to facilitate trades.
Now is it trying to give you good trades?
No.
It's trying to move and rebook and reprice to levels to allow those in the know to participate.
It's a rigged game.
You're not supposed to be in it.
Not consistently profitable, let's say it that way, but for those that are in the know,
they're looking for these types of signatures and price action.
So they know what they're looking for in terms of when they're going to operate.
So as a technician, they're looking for a specific element of time, which is encapsulated
with this segment right here, seven o'clock to ten o'clock.
So that little bracket of time right there on a five minute chart, you're hunting your
setup.
What is the thresholds that make it high probability?
Well, if you're going short or looking to go short and you want to be above the midnight
opening price, that's here, extended out in time.
But now once we hit this order block here, that was during the early stages of the New
York open right around the seven o'clock hour.
The market drops and then retraces back into that news driver here at ten.
So what's happening here is look closely with this swing low.
It went below this low here and then it rallied back up once more above the opening price
at midnight.
Does it take out this high?
No.
Why doesn't it take out this high?
Because it has an imbalance here.
That imbalance tells you this is an intermediate term high.
If we're bearish, it shouldn't take this high out.
Now again, I mentioned this in a recent video.
I think if I'm not mistaken, it was episode 12.
I'm going by memory, so please don't roast me in the comment section if that's the wrong
one.
But it's basically when I'm talking about intermediate term and short term and long
term highs and lows or swing highs and lows.
An imbalance or a fair value gap associated with a swing high or swing low, in this case
this is an intermediate term high.
Not because it just simply has an imbalance, but because the narrative is we're expecting
lower prices and it went above the opening price at midnight and the imbalance there
when it retraces back up into this fake run ahead of the news driver at 10 o'clock.
The news, if you will.
This movement here is only running right back up into the bearish order block.
Last up close candle, the body.
I don't like to use these long tails and wicks.
I'll refer to them, but I'd like to prefer to annotate if I'm going to show it in my
examples or look to price returning back to the body of the candle.
So this return into that order block sets the stage for another move lower.
We get a swing high, lower high to the right of this candle and a lower high to the left
of it here.
So we have three candles making a swing high.
So we start looking for displacement and movement lower.
Looking closer, after we had that shift in market structure here on a five minute chart,
it retraces back up, fair value gap, bearish order block, and news.
This is the wild card.
When you have high impact news drivers, this is going to many times scare you out of the
trade or stop you out in the words.
If you went short back here and you started trailing your stop loss, this is what that's
designed to do, take you out.
So if you're short back here or here or here, how are you protecting the trade?
You're putting up a buy stop above recent swing highs.
So they're jamming it up against that back above the opening price because your buy stops
going to flood the market with buyers willing to pay a higher price than it was here before
it runs higher and you're going to buy or those individuals that had their stops, they're
going to buy the counterparty side of the smart money that wants to sell short because
every buyer has to have a seller, every seller has to have a buyer.
So that's what's occurring here.
But inside this shaded area, I want to show you how this model is applicable here in FX.
So here's the four minute chart.
We were just looking at five.
So we start stripping down this price leg here and we're looking for any fair value
gap.
Do you see it?
Pause the video.
Look for it.
All right, I'm about to show you.
This candle's low.
This candle's high.
There's your fair value gap.
Isn't it interesting how this goes right up in there, closes that in, then and only then
the market starts to aggressively run below the short term low here and then reaching
into our objective down here at that 109 big figure.
Now it doesn't quite get to 1.09 even, but it does get to our Fibonacci extension for
the standard deviation.
It does get down to the old relative equal lows on the daily chart, which is what that
blue line is.
Look at the bodies respecting that level.
Not much movement below it.
Now for all of you raw dogs out there, okay, this is too much, Michael.
You're overcomplicating it.
You're confusing me, Michael.
You're talking about the midnight candle for the opening price and now you're talking
about the 8.30.
Which one do I use?
Why do I use it?
This, that, I don't think.
All right.
If you're going to be trading FX, you're going to be using the 8.30 in the morning for New
York Session trades, but refer to the New York open at midnight as well.
If the opening price is lower at the 8.30 than that of the opening price at midnight,
use the lower one.
Reason why is you want to set the minimum threshold for a Judas swing or a market protraction
to the upside when you're bearish.
And everything that I just said would be reversed if you're bullish.
You'd be looking for a move below the opening at 8.30 to go long after it moves below it.
But we're focusing primarily on the shorting opportunity here in hindsight so that way
you can get a better feel for how to use this model with FX.
So there's a subtle little group of nuances that you have to be aware of when you're looking
at FX, but it's not terribly, you know, harsh.
It's pretty easy to work with.
So we have the market trading above the opening price here.
Market protraction, Judas swing, it rallies up and then breaks down in here.
Now this run here above the opening price, does it have a fair value gap?
Here's the four minute chart.
Opening price now doesn't look the same because we're looking at a four minute chart.
So it was anchored on a five minute chart.
It rallies up and break lower.
Fair value gap right there, trades up into it, hammers it beautifully, and then displacement
trades lower down into that 109, what was it, 1.0901 something or other.
I can't remember what thought I had, but it hit it.
And I think the low of the day was 1.0901.
So not bad, I mean, it's pretty close to perfect, right?
But by itself, you don't want to try to aim for just that level because that's the best
exit strategy.
You don't want to do that.
You want to fluff up your exits with a couple pips.
I like to teach my students three to five pips.
And if you're thinking a target is going to be like, for instance, we'll say 1.0900 level.
If that's what you think it's going to trade to, put your limit order to cover your shorts
if you're short at 1.0905.
You're not going to get the best exit that way, but you have a spread that you have to
incorporate when you're working with 4X and FX pairs.
And I've had a lot of this happen over the years as an FX trader where my limit order
was a little too overzealous.
I was trying to be a little too perfect.
And I've had many amazing exits elude me because of my overzealous targeting.
So be a little bit more forgiving when you're trading, especially 4X, you've got to incorporate
the spread.
And I know some of you have brokers where it's like, oh, I have a really tight spread.
Let me tell you something.
Every broker has the ability to open that spread up on you.
You're seeing the best case scenario when that ticker is showing.
But trust me, when it's advantageous for them, they'll work it in their behalf, not yours.
So make it easier for yourself.
Just fluff up your exits with five pips.
And if you're really new, just use 10 pips.
And if you're struggling with the idea that, oh, I don't want to do that, I'll give up
Well, let me show you this.
This would be your entry candle, trading right back to this old high here.
So one pip at or thereabouts.
Once it hits that candle with this run here, that right there would be your entry candle.
Your stop would be right above this candle's high.
Now if you're scared or whatever, you can use this swing high and that's fine.
Now in terms of math, the entry price would be 1.09653 and your stop would be 1.09728
hypothetically.
That's not a lot of pips.
I would generally round that to 10.
Even though it's not technically 10 pips here, I would round it to 10 and just be done with
it.
And looking at that model here, and you're aiming for that essentially 1.09 big figure,
bluffing it up a little bit so our exit price would be a little bit higher than that.
You guys see these things all the time and I just felt like using it, you know, just
because I want to be cool.
The risk is here.
Entry to stop and the distribution to your target down here.
Risk to reward ratio better than 8 to 1 and using a hypothetical $100,000 demo account
if you're doing one of those funded account challenges or whatever.
In this trade here, this gives you basically what you're looking for in one trade.
I don't know if this scratches the itch for you, but the stuff works in Forex.
It works in index trading.
So it's a matter of adjusting to what it is you're trying to trade and then there's a
little bit of rule following that you have to know when it comes to index trading and
FX.
FX predominantly, you're working with 7 o'clock in the morning to 10 o'clock in the morning.
That's your New York open kill zone.
Index trading, I'm focusing on 830 to 11 and I can take a trade all the way up to 1040-1045
and still be okay.
I'm not interested in taking new trades generally after 10 o'clock in the morning in the FX pair
unless there is a news driver like we had this morning with the ISM number, the PMI number I
mentioned earlier in the video.
So that was allowing me to be a little bit more forgiving with expectations for price.
You may not want to trade high impact news drivers and that's understandable if you don't
know what you're doing, but don't be afraid of them.
Now with the economic counter having that high impact news driver at 10 o'clock that
extends the New York session kill zone into the 11, 1130 time window because the volatility
that it will bring in.
Now, I didn't take this trade.
I haven't taken any FX pair trades at all, not for 2022 at least, but if you're looking at a model
that works in index futures, you're looking at that 830 to 11 o'clock window and if you're
trying to apply this model to FX, it's 7 o'clock in the morning to 10 o'clock in the morning.
Now, the high impact news drivers that come out after 10 o'clock, like for instance, if
you're a Canadian dollar trader and the crude oil inventory number comes out usually like 1030 in
the morning, you have to make allowances for that and just expect there'd be a likely move
on that oil number at 1030.
So just something to throw out there.
I know a lot of you've been barking wanting to see something FX related because you know
predominantly I've been doing that since 2010, but I humbly submit this for your
inquiry and that way you can study this and listen to it a few times.
It has a couple of things in there that may have went over your head.
It's not terribly demanding in terms of note taking, but there's some things in here that
are noteworthy for you to have in your study journal.
And for the most part it looks like it works pretty good in this pair too
or in this asset class.
So until I talk to you again on Thursday, be safe.